- Is Montana in the Midwest
or out of the Midwest?
Nobody knows.
(playful music)
- Every state that's not on the East Coast
or West Coast sounds like a Midwest state.
(playful music)
- [Voiceover] Is Tennessee
a part of the Midwest?
- North Dakota, South Dakota.
- These are easy because
they're pretty much the same things.
- I hope I know where Iowa is.
I've been there.
- Iowa. I have, oh boy.
- Wait, is this a state?
This is water.
- Iowa could be any one of these.
- I'm gonna guess this
is Iowa right there.
- Iowa is right there.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- Ohio.
- Ohio seems weird to me,
so I just thought it was over here.
- Illinois is gonna be right here. Bingo.
- Wisconsin, Wisconsin.
- This is Wisconsin.
- I'm pretty sure this is Wisconsin.
I know it's kinda close to the top.
- Minnesota.
- I think we share a border with Canada.
(laughs) I don't know.
- Okay so Minnesota's there
and then this is Idaho.
- Idaho is there.
- Idaho. I'm just putting this here.
This looks like a great
spot for some potatoes.
- So where does Indiana go?
I'm actually confused now.
- Forgot about Indiana.
- Is Indiana in this?
- Wait, Missouri isn't
one of these, is it?
- I'm almost 100% sure
Missouri's a Southern state.
- This is Missouri. I know
this is Missouri 'cause I met
a lot of wonderful people from Missouri.
- Nebraska. What? I thought Nebraska.
- Kansas is there.
No it's not, it's here.
- [Voiceover] Yep.
- Arkansas. Is that in this?
- As most Midwesterners can attest,
West Coast people and East Coast people
know nothing about the Midwest.
It's okay.
- [Justin] What, no! No.
- [Justin] I didn't even have that.
- [Andrew] Everything's gonna be okay.
- It's a pass?
- I feel like you could
date a Midwesterner
and it would be like, okay.
Like they would accept you.
- [Justin] Okay. That's fine.
- This is really solid.
The Midwest would be very happy with this.
We'd invite you to a meat raffle.
- A meat raffle? Oh boy, what's that?
- This is really good.
All of them are correct
except for this one,
but in fairness, pretty similar names.
- (laughs) No offense to all
the people of Idaho and Iowa.
- Ms. Lesqueut, is Zack's
fifth grade Geography teacher,
if you're watching this.
- Do I have a state here
that's not even in the Midwest?
- You have plenty of states
here that's not in the Midwest.
- I'm a big fan of the Midwest.
- Well you should come sometime
and we can show ya around.
- I don't think you guys
want me there (laughs).
- [Andrew] Why don't they
just make it a giant Dakota?
Like look how big Minnesota is.
I feel like they coulda
just made one big Dakota.
- The main takeaway of this video
is that nobody knows where Idaho is.
So Midwesterners, if you ever complain
that nobody knows where your state is,
at least you don't live in Idaho.
(laughter)